what's going on guys in this review i'm
going to be breaking down episode 14 of
attack on titan season 4
in which aaron beat the shutout of armin
and zeke summoned a titan army to kill
levi
as many of you know the official release
of this episode was delayed last week
due to an earthquake
which meant that episodes 14 and 15 came
out today instead
today i'll be talking about the parts
from episode 14 that i felt needed
explaining
including why erin said he hated mikasa
vlogs descent into madness
and why levi's plan to have zeke eaton
makes no sense
before we get into it remember that the
season finale of attack on titan is
coming next week so if you want to watch
it as soon as it's available
then go to crunchyroll.com turtlequirk
that link will get you a two-week free
trial of crunchyroll premium
where next weekend you can watch both
the finale of attack on titan
and the premiere of maher academia just
hours after they air in japan
all episodes are in hd and
professionally subtitled so take it from
me crunchyroll is the best place to
check these series out
not to mention it also supports the
anime industry thanks to them for
sponsoring this video
and be sure to get your free trial by
going to crunchyroll.com
link is in the description okay so
episode 14 was called savagery which is
possibly the most perfect title of the
season
given just how many savages were in this
episode alone
following on from his absurdly casual
entrance aaron sits down to have a chat
with amin mikasa
and also gabby because she just happens
to be there these guys haven't had a
proper conversation since before he went
to infiltrate marley by himself
so this meeting is a way for them to
catch up despite claiming it was going
to be a peaceful discussion
from the beginning aaron made everyone
keep their hands on the table whilst his
hand was cut
meaning he could turn into a titan at
any time with the power of the warhammer
he is able to use the power of the
titans in enclosed spaces
and we saw this in the manga when he
escaped from prison that makes this
scenario more similar to a hostage
situation than a quiet chat
as clearly aaron knew things would turn
ugly from the start throughout this
season so far
characters have speculated that aaron is
being controlled by zeke but here he
rejects that notion
and declares he is a free man who is
acting of his own free will
we know this is true based on what we
saw in episode 15 as we can see that
he's not being controlled by zeke but
rather he's just going along with zeke's
plan voluntarily
i'll be talking about this more in my
review of episode 15 itself but to
summarize it here
aaron and zeke's plan is to stop aliens
from reproducing and they can only do
this once they make contact
because then aaron can use the power of
the founding titan this will gradually
end the ldn race without the need for
conflict
but in order to fulfill that plan aaron
has to do certain things he doesn't want
to do
this tough conversation is one of those
things and i'll explain why he's being
so rude to armando mikasa later in this
video
anyway he reveals to the group that he
spoke to zeke whilst undercover in mali
and from that discussion he learned many
things about the ackermann clan
and also how berto's memories might be
affecting armin
starting with the ackerman stuff because
that's more interesting aaron claims the
reason mikasa is so strong
is due to the acumens being a
genetically modified bloodline
mikasa's powers activated the day she
killed that kidnapper and it was eren
that caused it to happen
his command telling mikasa to fight sent
a surge of electricity through her body
and it was clear that she instantly
became stronger in that moment
ordinarily you'd think being a super
soldier is a good thing but aaron's
problem is that mikasa's desire to
protect him is due to her acumen blood
in the same way that acumens of the past
would protect the king mikasa's genetics
are supposedly wired to protect eren
because he is the one that activated her
powers in other words
her attachment towards him all these
years has not been out of free will
but rather she's being controlled by her
dna he puts this theory to the test in a
ridiculous way
by intentionally saying things to
provoke armin and mikasa
the point he's trying to make here is
that even though he's saying things to
make her retaliate
she is still genetically unable to
attack him the most shocking part was
when he looks her dead in the eyes
and says that he's always hated her ever
since they were kids it was honestly
such an insane sentence to see coming
out of aaron's mouth
but if we take a look back through the
series it's obvious that he's lying
you don't punch a titan with your bare
hands to protect someone you hate that's
just not something people do
so i think that this image alone is
enough to prove that you know he's
clearly not always hated her
the question then becomes what does he
gain from lying to his friends and
insulting them
and to me the most logical reason is
that aaron is trying to push them away
aaron knows his friends will not support
what he's planning to do and so by
pushing them away
he is strengthening his own resolve to
follow through with it think about it
if they were all still friends then
maybe these two could convince him to
take a different path
so by making sure they're on bad terms
aaron now has no one holding him back
i believe that's why he also insulted
armin but before we talk about that
i want to mention something that pixie
said a few episodes ago
when previously talking to elena the
commander stated the best way to notice
a good lie
is when the person lying adds in a bit
of truth in elena's case
she told the truth that she met aaron
but pixis knew she was lying about what
they discussed
in zeke's case he told the truth that
his spinal fluid can turn aliens into
titans
but lied when he said it would make
people freeze up and that line showed
that nobody suspected the wine
when it comes to error now yes he may
have said a couple things that we know
to be true
but most of what he's saying cannot be
backed up by any reliable source
with a quick example being what he said
about mikis's headaches he claimed that
these headaches are the result of
mikasa's true self trying to resist
being controlled but if that's true
why we never heard of something similar
from kenny levi or even levi's great
grandfather i mean that guy was spilling
all the secrets
like pixis we have to be skeptical when
it comes to things said by leaders of
this rebellion because at this point
they're just saying anything to get the
advantage
moving over to armin one truth that eren
correctly assumed
was that he's still going to visit annie
and her titan crystal the wording
implies the army has been doing this for
a while
and aaron thinks that berto's memories
are what's causing this behavior
whether it's true or not doesn't really
matter since either way
it plays into aaron's tactic to distance
himself from his friends
and strengthen his resolve i'm pretty
sure it hasn't even been a full week
since he relied on these guys
to help him out during the battle of
liberio and during that battle he showed
no hatred towards them
at all for him to then suddenly claim
that ahmed and mikasa don't have free
will
and that he hates people who don't have
free will yeah it's obviously not
genuine
and like i said we know the reason why
he's doing this his continued mockery of
miku said leads to armand dishing out a
colossal punch to the face
but the way he just takes it is
hilarious i feel like aaron is a person
who is just going through the motions
right now which is part of the reason
why he looks so tired but that didn't
stop him from still teaching armin a
lesson
he dodged the successive punches with
basically no effort and his brutality
towards armin was way more profound in
animated form
aaron then tells his guards to take gabi
mikasa and armin away
as all of them are going on a road trip
to shiganchina we know from later in the
episode that shiganshina is likely where
aaron and zeke are meant to meet each
other
as zeke wonders if his brother still
remembers the place they agreed
assuming that eren does remember the
location that zeke's referring to
then him heading to shiganchina is a bit
of a giveaway speaking of zeke
the anime then switches over to the
forest where he's being held hostage
as levi prepares to start cutting him up
to summarize levi's thought process here
he doesn't want the military to eat eren
like pixar's is planning to do
but rather he wants to fulfill his
promise to irwin by feeding the beast
titan to someone instead
this idea from levi is just terrible
because if the beast titan is given to
someone without real blood
then the island of parodies is screwed
zeke's royal-bladed titan is the key
that will allow aaron to use the
founding titan if eren can't use the
founding titan then that means he can't
activate the rumbling
and if you can't do that then parodies
island will be helpless if the world
launches a revenge attack on the island
just for those of you that might not be
sure what the rumbling actually is
essentially with the power of the
founding titan aaron can release the
colossus titans within the wars of
parodies
and if they were to use it then other
nations would most likely back off
historia is the only other person of
royal blood who can inherit the beast
titan
and right now she's pregnant so she
can't do it and who knows maybe there
will be complications maybe she'll die
during pregnancy
we just don't know so it's not a risk
worth taking
in my opinion levi's judgment is clouded
by his desire to fulfill that promise to
irwin
and this is a rare example of him
prioritizing his own emotions
over the survival of aliens on parodies
while zeke was rereading his book
he was already subtly getting ready for
his escape as he checks with levi if
there's any wine left
this was his way of confirming that all
of the soldiers have been contaminated
with spinal fluid
meaning he can turn all 30 of them into
pure titans
after a quick stretch zeke absolutely
legs it while screaming at the top of
his lungs
zeke's scream turned all of levi's men
into pure titans while everyone else on
parodies who drunk the wine
felt a surge of electricity through
their body people like falco and pixis
were all contaminated
but on this occasion they weren't
titanized because they aren't within
range of zeke's scream
in the past zeke has created pure titans
that pretty much act like we expect but
in this situation they are all
definitely abnormals they're incredibly
fast and can climb up the trees
which would have made this an impossible
situation to survive for anyone else
other than captain levi
however it does go without saying that
levi still doesn't want to kill his
soldiers
but when backed into a corner he is more
than able to do so
this shot right here was my favorite of
the episode because the absolute chaos
of the pure titans
is nicely contrasted by the composure
and stoicism of levi
anyhow given that zeke controls the pure
titans he creates
he uses one of them to hitch a ride
while the other two remained there as
backup
his goal was to exit the forest and meet
aaron at the location they agreed
but what he wasn't counting on was that
god mode levi had already dealt with the
other titans
from the moment zeke was forced to turn
into the beast there are a few reasons
why he never stood a chance
number one although the beast titan is
technically a monkey
zeke himself is not capable of climbing
trees or swinging in any way
which meant he was stuck on the ground
while levi was free to maneuver
around him levi could therefore hide
behind trees to evade whatever zeke
threw at him
and he obscured zeke's vision by hiding
behind the branches he chopped off
additionally there were no rocks in the
area so the beast desperately resorted
to throwing titan brains and other
unsavory body parts
the way he just tore it apart like a
nothing piece of meat it was kind of
funny to see that
but unfortunately it doesn't pack the
same punch as what he normally throws
overall levi was in control of this
fight from start to finish
and his thunder spears were enough to
pierce the beast titan's nape in one go
when these two fought back in
shiganshina the captain was so fast that
zeke didn't have time to harden his nape
so it's ironic that this time around
zeke did manage to harden it but it just
didn't mean anything
with the thunderspears detonating the
oldest yeager brother was turned into a
mushy human
barely hanging onto life and in this
state levi is ready to serve him up to
anyone who's prepared to eat him
one thing worth pointing out is that in
the manga it was confirmed that the
survey called newbies are the ones who
gave levi's soldiers the wine
survey corps recruits had already
planted the bomb that killed zachary
and leaked government info about eren so
this is yet another crime that we can
add to their list
most of the survey corps recruits want
the jaegers to cease power
because the existing military leadership
has failed to adapt with the times
we see this in the following scene where
instructor shadis insists
that all the new recruits learn about
killing titans despite the island's main
threat now coming from humans on the
outside world
it is fair to believe that his way of
thinking is outdated and we could tell
that a lot of the new recruits did not
have faith in him
keith heard the comment that one of them
made and if you're familiar with his
backstory
then you'll know why those words seem to
disappoint him so much for those that
might not know
keith shadis was the old commander of
the survey court during his time as
commander
he failed to get any significant results
and he would often be the only one to
survive
expeditions one day he came to the
realization that while special people
like irwin do exist in the world
keith himself was not one of them and
became the first commander in the
history of the survey
corps to resign rather than being killed
by a titan
to have a backstory like that it must
hurt when even as a mere instructor
the newbies think someone else should be
in charge the jaegers then make a grand
entrance
and in keeping with his new villainous
persona flock immediately fires a
warning shot
his goal in coming here was to recruit
survey called newbies to join the
yaegris
and this was a quick detour they were
taking before hanji brings them to zeke
when some of the recruits began to
switch allegiance and join the egress
flock confirmed that he is now mentally
insane by ordering the newbies to beat
up instructor chadis
this was his twisted way of testing
their resolve but if you wanted to i'm
sure there's like a hundred
less sadistic methods of doing this you
could tell that even the cervical
recruits were like what the hell are we
getting ourselves into but they did
obviously still go ahead with it
i would go as far as to say that flock
is the character with the most drastic
personality change since season three
i mean he never showed even a hint of
this attitude beforehand in fact he was
more wussy than most survey corps
members out there
at least when it came to aaron you know
his attack on molly wasn't that
surprising
i mean yeah he killed women and children
so that is a bit out of character
but still he's always had that
destructive revenge filled mindset so it
wasn't too surprising whereas with flock
it is just like where did this come from
back outside the forest levi holds zeke
hostage in a genius way
because if he moves his neck then this
cable would detonate a thundersphere in
his stomach
even for a titan shifter that would
probably kill them so the beast titan is
in a really tough situation
he continues to get tortured by levi and
strictly speaking the reason levi is
doing this
is so that deep doesn't regenerate and
therefore you know have the ability to
transform
but being real levi probably wanted to
do this anyway zeke wonders where his
iconic glasses have gone
and a flashback takes us back into his
childhood where we see a young zeke
playing catch with one of marley's
warriors
this guy was the former beast titan but
i will be talking about that more in my
review of episode 15
as that episode just had the whole thing
whereas for this episode you know this
is all we got be sure to hit that sub
button so you don't miss the video on
episode 15
and like i said if you want to watch the
season finale as soon as it drops
then click the link in my description to
get your two-week crunchyroll free trial
it's what i've used to watch the entire
season so far and also what i'll be
using to watch my hero season 5
so i do recommend checking it out thanks
for watching as always and until the
next one
peace out